yeah it's gonna be another bullpen day
for the marlins i guess it comes at a
decent time you had the seven innings
last night from braxton garrett you've
got the day off tomorrow so
if you have to empty the bucket out
there you do so this will be his 34th
game and second start
for john curtis ball and two strikes
on grisham and that's in there for a
called strike three
a good start for curtis dials up the
inside corner
two and two from curtis and it's a swing
and a miss
goes to the elevated fastball and
kronenworth chased
you darvish will go to work marlins come
to the plate in the bottom of the first
jace tingler is out there talking to
bill miller
oh played umpire i i don't know
what's up other than you darvish is
hanging around home plate too i don't
know
what that's about we're told that it was
something over the number of pitchers he
was throwing to warm up
and bill miller told him he only had one
and that would be it
he wanted two more and he said one more
yeah one more you got one more
he's like i want two a couple last night
martay goes throw from carrottini
is into the runner and marta able to
hang on to the bag so another stolen
base for starling marte
and that is his 20th of the season so a
nice round number for starling martay
swinging a miss and darvish strikes out
aguilar
nicely done there fooled him badly first
strikeout for darvish two down two balls
two strikes two duvall
got to be a breaking ball down and away
right here there you go there you go
chases that slider back-to-back
strikeouts for darvish he gets aguilar
and duvall with a runner at second base
they are playing in the outfield for fam
to go the other way he grounds this one
softly towards third
anderson picks and fires and it gets off
the glove of aguilar
so fam is headed for second base he'll
get there without a problem that got a
long way away
zagular could not make the catch on that
and now heading for third is fam
throw will go there and he'll be safe
good base running by tommy pham
caught everybody kind of napping there
for the marlins took a look around
and just takes off for third after he
had fully stopped at second base yeah
don't nap on the friars
wayne kirby says second base it was
arguable you know what somebody said
something to him he looked into the
crowd
did you see that kind of put his head
down and fam noticed and just yeah
he said i'm taking off gone and he gets
there yeah
so runner third brings the infield in
all the way around with only one out in
the inning
this is gonna get off the second baseman
panic into right and fam will score
hosmer drives in the first run of the
game padres take a one-nothing lead
this one out toward right center field
and hit well martay turns and
looks that is going to one-hop the wall
osmer getting the green light
now changing his mind runs through the
stop sign and is out of the play
third base coach bobby dickerson was
waving hosmer around
and then put up the stop sign and hosmer
kept going and he's out by 10 feet
this has got to be a little bit more on
hosmer than it's going to be on
dickerson
one two two leon good running fastball
strikes him out third k
for you darvish play two in miami padres
have a one nothing lead
22 years old a-rod did it to 22 his
teammate manny machado at 22.
andrew jones was 21 acuna junior 21 and
mike trout was
20 years old when he did it in 2012 but
here
oaker strikes him out and that's his
fifth strikeout this series in fact
runner goes they've got him picked off
throw from aguilar
is right on the money marrero applied
the tag
and grisham is out nice job by everybody
involved aguilar taking the throw
creating a nice throwing lane
zogert picks to first all about the
footwork
job by aguilar good strong throw
one two from ochre and he gets him to
chase the slider away
a strikeout for stephen oaker two in the
inning
devin marrero called up for the second
time joined the club yesterday he's in
the lineup today
252 at jacksonville in 43 games with
five home runs and four doubles
marrero into right field gives it a ride
and it's gone
home run for devon marrero down the
right field line
[Applause]
wow his first home run since 2017 with
the red sox
that carried right on out of here that
is
not easy to do again the fish
look like they are fully prepared to
just run out as many guys as they need
to
to get through this game and he swings
on 01. sends one in the air deep center
marte going back this one going to go
just over the 400 marker and straight
away center field
bouncing around those bushes and a rude
welcome to the game for anthony bender
as manny hits his 17th of the year
and the padres go back in front 2-1
105.4 off the bat of manny machado this
is a
laser to center field 1-2 on anderson
who flew out to left his first time up
and it's into right field anderson hits
it deep
anderson hits it out a solo home run to
the opposite field marlins have tucked
two down there today
pulls the hands in cartini wanted that
ball down
and away that is a big time miss by
darvish
easy to elevate and just enough to get
it out
2-2 and a swing and a miss as leone
strikes out that's strikeout number five
for you darvish
second time leone's down by way of the k
rbi opportunity for magneris sierra
and he'll do just that yeah
pass machado down the line sierra to
second
in there and the marlins take the lead
first rbi for magnarise sierra
marte ground ball base hit into right
center field sierra will score easily
marte tacks on a run four to two miami
[Applause]
runners go and now they've got tatis
caught in between
second and third panic complies the tag
looks like the marlins guessed right on
an inside move there yeah they sure did
both guys broke
way too early almost tell
with tatis last two pitches to home the
lead was getting a little bit bigger
of course machado the trail runner he's
watching tatis and
he's gonna make it into second base
easily
payoff pitch from bass in there for a
cold strike three
throws him on the slider here's leon now
two strikeouts today
he's got the chance to erase all of that
with a big swing here they could use the
breathing room
they might get it that's in the corner
and that's a fair ball
duvall will score easily here comes ba
leon on his way to second he will hold
up right there with a
two rbi double and the marlins take a
6-2 lead
and brinson is going to turn that one
around that is a
deep shot crush to left louis
brinson three-run shot marlins blow it
open
when he's given the chance to play he
has responded since his return
struck out six and he is on the hook
to left center and profar dives to make
the catch in left
juricks and profile laying it out to
make the grab nicely done
well the marlins will strand a pair but
it's all thanks to profar
fly ball hit of the air to deep right
field back goes duvall
at the wall and that ball is gone
home run for o'grady padres not going
quietly a solo shot
makes it nine to three here it comes
and a swing and a miss it's a marlins
win